welcome back to CBS this morning we
could soon get a clearer picture of the
devastating toll the pandemic has had on
nursing homes more than 15,000 nursing
homes had to submit their first reports
on coronavirus deaths and infections to
the federal government by last night CBS
News has confirmed that of the more than
89 thousand deaths from the corona virus
or than 28,000 were connected to nursing
homes nearly a third of the total as
Jonathan Vigliotti reports a lack of
staff could have made the problem worse
I feel like I'm lying to him when I tell
him I'm going to see him soon so he
doesn't give up Lisa cooks husband Bruce
who suffered two strokes is recovering
at the Stony Point health care center
near Los Angeles before coronavirus she
says Bruce had made progress through
months of speech and physical therapy
cook is now worried he's declining and
she's concerned about his care the
actual caregivers there are my Angels I
called them but they don't have time to
look after him the way you know I mean
they don't have the time Bruce is
absolutely at their mercy
at least 14 Stony Point residents and
eight staff members have tested positive
for kovat 19 California advocates for
nursing home reform filed a complaint
with the state about conditions at the
facility during the outbreak a report
issued by the California Department of
Public Health found a deficiency in
infection prevention and control
including a nurse entering a residence
isolation room without wearing PPE and
then grabbing a cart without cleaning
his or her hands how does that make you
feel to know that this is a place that
is supposed to be taking care of your
husband it makes me mad and it makes me
scared because that's unacceptable but I
know it probably happens because they're
overworked and understaffed the Centers
for Medicare and Medicaid Services gave
Stony Point a below average rating for
staffing
dark is an attorney with California
advocates for nursing home reform
understaffing
is really the original sin of the
nursing home industry in that so many
other problems like neglect like
infection control really stemmed from it
and that was the case long before this
virus showed up there are no federal
regulations on staffing levels but
federally certified nursing homes are
required to have a licensed nurse on
duty CBS News found that roughly one in
fifteen US nursing homes was cited last
year for failing to meet standards for
sufficient nursing staff now the
outbreak which has sickened workers and
prompted others to stay at home is
hurting staffing levels even more is
that the conditions are far worse than
they ever have been april Verret is
president of SEIU Local 2015
California's largest union which
represents one quarter of the state's
nursing home workers Farah says the
median salary for nursing home workers
is about $23,000 a year other could say
operators need to increase pay and hire
more employees they also want the family
members to be allowed back if they've
been tested and have proper PPE for him
to recover or any other patient that's
in there or to stay well they have to
have their families there they
absolutely do and there's got to be a
way and we reached out to stony point
about the inspection report the facility
said we take such reports seriously and
this one was no exception and I quote we
took immediate corrective action upon
receiving the notice and instilled
additional training for all staff
members on proper infection control
procedures the facility says they have
an unwavering commitment to provide the
highest level of care Lisa Cooke who you
heard from there she says that should
include allowing families back into
nursing homes gail we feel for Lisa cook
Jonathan I see why she's mad and scared
we're pulling for Bruce and everybody
else in that situation thank you very
much